stéphane bern bonjour bonjour merci
d'avoir accepté notre invitation merci a
vous de me tester un plaisir partagé
parce que le sujet est très riche vous
êtes est ce qu'on peut dire un yvelinois
de coeur ou un versailles et de coeur
cousu le jeu tellement passé de temps à
versailles que forcément je me sens un
peu chez moi c'est ce que je trouve
voilà je skie ce qui est formulée avec
ce château de versailles et toute la
ville de versailles et comme un musée
c'est louvain c'est que au fond ça
appartient à la nation tout engagement
donc choc ce qui est étrange cette voie
je suis toujours étonné de voir que si
peu de français visitent il ya 75 %
d'étrangers qui se rendent au château de
versailles c'est à dire que c'est un peu
la lumière de la france tout le monde
sur la france est le premier pays visité
au monde tout le monde a envie d'aller à
versailles mais je trouve que les
maintenant il ya tout un travail à faire
du côté envers les français pour que les
franciliens d'abord puis en français et
a envie de venir au château de
versailles je trouve que c'est un
endroit magique en convient mais je
trouverai une annonce que même le verset
mais il connaît un verset vous prenez
bien mais on oublie quelquefois de
regarder là comme un comme un joyau
comme un endroit merveilleux et on
oublie que
je veux dire c'est que on oublie de
regarder et s'émerveiller parfois bon
alors n'oubliez pas jouer j'adore
voyager tous les prétextes sont bons
pour tourner des émissions que
beaucoup d'émissions là je suis en train
de faire un prime sur les 400 ans de
d'andré le nôtre et atlanta c'est une
promenade à la fois historiques
artistiques dans les jardins de
versailles dans l'orangerie et je veux
dire c'est un émerveillement l'autre
jour vous avez en plus vu du ciel c'est
magique on a mano et des drones qui vous
aident à filmer en a filmé j'ai vu pour
la première fois l'orangerie vu du ciel
mais ça c'est d'une perfection total à
venir dont les oranges et son plein
c'est vu du ciel c'est absolument
magique
s'élancer de marchi cet escalier qui va
jusqu'à la pièce d'eau des suisses mais
c'est quelque chose d'unique au monde je
trouve qu'il ya une beauté une
architecture et vous savez quoi moi je
vois versailles au fond comme une
vitrine de la france je pense que c'est
comme ça que 1014 devez vous lui il
avait voulu que ce soit au fond que les
étrangers qui se rendent là se disent
incroyable et c'est un show room
exactement c'est une vitrine et heller
carrie qui était le doj de gem qui
arrive à versailles le le roi louis xiv
lui demande mais qu'est ce qui vous a le
plus surpris à versailles il y aurait
pondu mais c'est de me voir si mes
jetons c'est vrai que il faut toujours
s'émerveiller d'y être voilà on va faire
ça c'est nous ivoire qui vient bon donc
vous on vous y voit beaucoup oui j'ai un
travail beaucoup mais j'ai l'impression
que vous avez là la conquête d'un
nouveau public avec les enfants c'est
nouveau ça oui c'était une façon de
parce que vous savez je fais mes livres
secrets d'histoire tous les ans il ya eu
un thomas voilà on va sortir le cadre à
la fin de l'année après la salve d'aidés
des émissions qui vont passer cet été et
je me suis dit c'est bon d'être ici est
obsédé par ce que parce qu'elle
rencontrait les les parents qui a acheté
le livre nommé vous n'est rien pour nos
enfants et cédric dans les salons du
livre les gens me disent mais nos
enfants ont besoin ou envie aussi de
s'intéresser s donc vous avez pris les
choses en main et je me suis dit
pourquoi ne pas faire une version pour
les enfants à la pour les 7 11 ans et de
se dire mais eux aussi ont peut-être
vous avez les jeunes aujourd'hui ont
tous des tablettes ils ont tous est il
sauterait vidéo étaient ils ont besoin
d'une image dynamique pourquoi les
livres pour les gamins sont toujours
aussi figé aussi rigide avec une
iconographie qu'est ce qui est sclérosé
lacroix qui l'ont mené l'étude du 3d
donc on aura des images en 3d avec des
tableaux avec marc on essaye de l'enfant
c'est moi la réponse est ce qu'ils
aiment et alors je vous avouerai que moi
qui l'ait lu j'ai révisé quelques
petites choses qui m'avait un peu
échappé est ce que j'aime beaucoup c'est
que le ton n'est pas mièvre n'est pas
enfantin voulant parler finalement alors
parler normalement mais voilà
normalement et c'est tout à fait de
sérieux l'urgent mais galan donc serait
pas écrire pour les enfants disant tiens
je ne garde
pas oui et on est obligé d'infantiliser
les gens que j'aime les enfants sont des
enfants mais en même temps ils sont
capables de comprendre le tout c'est
d'expliquer de raconter par exemple et
puis j'en profite parce que quand on
parle de monarchie absolue peut-être
raconter ce que le pouvoir absolu ces
terres sans lien ça veut donc dire que
il référait simplement et à dieu et aux
lois fondamentales du royaume ça empêche
pas là une sorte de démocratie vivante
ni siam et il faut expliquer les choses
parce que on a l'impression que c'est un
dictateur donc peut-être déjà prenait
donc remettre les pendules à l'heure et
puis il ya des quizz il ya des
questionnaires et vous dire oui alors là
vous aviez fait ça c'est génial parce
que sa peine ne soit lui dit voilà on la
retient jeu c'est la lecture pour les
enfants folle heureux c'est de la
gourmandise moi ce que ce que moi là je
ne supporte pas quand c'est comme ça on
va partager votre petit bout d'histoire
parce qu'elle a une mission c'est aux
autres histoire dépasse du pin ans
maintenant est donc juste le monde donc
on aura on à louis xiv qui est sorti
molière le molière napoléon
via l'égypte ancienne jeanne d'arc il va
y avoir
également jules césar il manque un
quatrième qui va me revenir bref ça sera
pour la rentrée de l'enfant et ceux là
sont déjà présents maintenant les grands
voilà alors moi j'ai adoré déjà le
format normal très sincères fait pour
mettre sur la table du nu c'était moi la
table dans un dîner vous savez vous avez
enfin moi c'est un peu mon genre faire
la maligne j'adore donc je m'essaie
soulane à ses écrits gros voiliers et je
peux citer des gens illustres l'air de
rien oui mais circule l'idée c'était de
rendre hommage à l'esprit français déjà
piailler la nuit non mais c'est tout ça
et dominer la plaisance c'est important
de dire que en france on a une chose
c'est que on avait le bel esprit c'est à
dire que on avait l'art de la réplique
l'art du du fleuret moucheté on savait
comment piques et répliques faire ça
piquait en même temps c'était des bons
mots
rivarol j'adore cette phrase une dame
dior monsieur combien quel âge me donnez
vous ou de madame vous en avez bien
assez et si c'était vrai ou où je pense
aussi à c'est à ce moment une dame se
tourner vers talleyrand lui dit monsieur
vous êtes vanter d'avoir eu mes faveurs
du rhône non madame pas vanté accusé
peut-être
ça c'est le bel esprit français que
j'adore
ces réponses bien piquante corrosif et
très drôle ne sont pas de la pure
provocation à nous nous avons en réponse
est une réponse est oui oui c'est
pratique 518 c'est chez du ping pong
c'est le tennis est allé lac c'est ça
que je trouve intéressant c'est de
montrer chaque fois qu'on peut avec un
peu d'esprit et puis c'est plein
philosophie je pense toujours à cette
phrase par exemple de talleyrand
toujours qui disent à propos de
châteaubriant monsieur de châteaubriant
se croit sourd depuis qu'il n'entend
plus parler de lui et on pourrait mettre
cette phrase pour tout le monde n'attend
rien de ce genre aujourd'hui c'est
prennent tellement au sérieux que il se
croit sourd depuis qu'ils ont fait
parler d'eux et
louis xviii d'ailleurs 10 est une chose
très intelligente aussi toujours sur ce
pauvre chateaubriand qui prend cher là
il disait il irait beaucoup plus loin
s'ils ne se mettait toujours devant lui
c'est très sucré il y avait aussi un
homme comme edgar faure qui avait
beaucoup beaucoup d'esprit
oui il était très drôle et une dame lui
dit il regardait son décolleté mais
monsieur vous avez vu comment vous me
dévisager et du nord madame je ne vous
dévisagent pas je vous envisage
la calme non mais l'était c'était très
flatteur pour elle mais il jouait sur
les danseuses oui jouer sur les mots
et légalement évidemment avec humour
avec un homme se tourne dans la
princesse de maternité lui qui était
l'ambassadrice d'autriche sous napoléon
iii et lui dit madame est ce que la
fumée de cigarette vous gêne et dire je
ne sais pas monsieur personne ne s'est
jamais permis de fumer en ma présence
faut le trouver un aujourd'hui oui parce
qu'aujourd'hui il ya plus ce bénéfice
est justement il ya de l'impertinence ya
de l'insolence et de là
vulgarité de la liberté
l'insolence et bones il ya de l'esprit
derrière c'était la culture voilà la
différence entre l'esprit et et
l'insolence et la culture et d'humour
mais justement il faut mais l'humour
n'est pas ne peut pas exister si y'a pas
tout ce background culturel c'est-à-dire
cette connaissance des us et des
coutumes des de l'histoire de la mode
oui ici hors scène on peut en jouer dès
lors qu'on les connaît bien sûr voilà et
alors moi j'ai remarqué que de gaulle
est très présent très très drôle de
gaulle très drôle très drôle voilà
malraux qui va aux toilettes à la
commune 2016 et malraux c'est paco lui
dire ils sont tous les deux a ajouté
l'un côte à côte dans une pissotière et
mal rôle dudit belles pièces en général
et le général lui répond regarder devant
vous malo évidemment il parlait de la
pièce de théâtre s à 2 pas d'autre chose
et il ya aussi celles de deux vols qui
dit quand un homme de dos mais lui dit
je suis plus grand vous en général mais
pâtit répond non vous êtes tellement
plus longue voilà
alors justement où sont les vivants
écoutez le jeu bien il ya un petit
giscard d'estaing ou et mieux très peu
très peu de vivants oui d'abord c'est
plus compliqué les vivants c'est à dire
les choses sur les sur les sur d'autres
vivent quand on veut ils l'ont fait ils
l'ont fait de leur vivant déjà et donc c
est resté dans l'histoire d'oksa c'est
plus compliqué avec les vivants parce
qu'ils ont parfois des mots d'esprit
mais c'est peut-être que je continuerai
parce que j'ai très envie d'en collecter
d'autres et de faire un deuxième tome je
rajouterais peut-être quelques vivant
mais je suis assez surpris un peu du
vivant autant d'esprit que les mais
voilà c'est ça qu'ils avaient envie
d'entendre et justement c'est
malheureusement ça ne se passe pas bien
sûr c'est
l'esprit de ces témoignages qui ont
écouté à part les répliques de nabil un
peu de choses sont réglées bilan
alou voilà on va arrêter bientôt d'en
rire je crois pas ça va pas rester mais
c'est vrai que c'est dommage que coûte
que 2 les gens ne donnent pas assez de
mal qu'il faut faut drainer du sien
aussi il faut avoir envie de me lier ces
décès d'une époque ça raconte une époque
oui déjà mais ce que les gens font ce
qu'il faut pour faire rire comme ça
gratuitement
non parce que moi pour faire rire on
peut faire rire bêtement mais attiré
raté déjà mon travail il faut un peu de
férocité aussi
vos projets vous continuez toujours la
radio à la bonne heure et tous les
matins sur l'incident comment ça va bien
après midi sur france 2 les secrets
d'histoire qui reprennent tout l'été et
puis à la rentrée il ya le jardin
préféré des français oui je viens on va
passer au jardin pour les journées du
patrimoine et alors ce film sur le nôtre
ça va se passer comment se passe le dieu
oui c'est en train de terminer de se
tourner ce sera le 2 juillet l'antenne
bon d'écouter un grand merci merci à
vous un s'étaient
rassemblés à bientôt au passage à
marseille le deuxième s'il vous plaît
parce que je vais pas répéter tout temps
la même chose en matinée merci merci et
à bientôt